let's find the volume of a few more
solid figures and then if we have time
we might be able to do some surface area
problems so let me draw a cylinder over
here so that is the top of my cylinder
and then this is the height
of my cylinder this is the bottom right
over here if this was transparent maybe
you could see the back side of the
cylinder so you can imagine this kind of
looks like a soda can and let's say that
the height
of my cylinder h is equal to eight i'll
get some units eight centimeters that is
my height and then let's say that the
radius of one of these of the top of my
cylinder of my soda can let's say that
this radius over here is equal to 4
centimeters so what is the volume here
what is the volume going to be
and the the the idea here is really the
exact same thing that we saw in some of
the previous problems if you can find
the surface area of one side
and then figure out kind of how deep it
goes you'll be able to figure out the
volume so we're going to do here is
figure out the surface area of the top
of this cylinder or the top of this soda
can and then we're going to multiply it
by its height and that'll give us a
volume this will tell us essentially how
many square centimeters fit in this top
and then if we know if we multiply that
how many by how many centimeters we go
down then that will give us the number
of cubic centimeters in this cylinder or
soda can so how do we figure out this
area up here
well the area of the top this is just
finding the area of a circle you can
imagine drawing it like this if we were
to just look at straight if we were just
look at it straight on that's a circle
with a radius of 4 centimeters the area
of a circle with radius 4 centimeters
area is equal to pi r squared so it's
going to be pi
times the radius squared times 4
centimeters squared which is equal to 4
squared is 16
times pi
and our units now are going to be
centimeters squared
centimeters squared or another way to
think of these are square centimeters so
that's the area the volume is going to
be this area times the height so the
volume is going to be equal to
pi
centimeters squared
centimeters
squared
times the height
times eight centimeters
times
eight centimeters
and so when you do multiplication you
can the associative property you can
kind of rearrange these things and the
commutative property we it doesn't
matter how what order you do if it's all
multiplication so this is the same thing
as 16 times 8 let's see 8 times e to 64
16 times 8 is twice that so it's going
to be 128
pi and you have centimeters squared
times centimeters so that gives us
centimeters
centimeters cubed or 128 pi cubic
centimeters remember pi is just a number
we write it as pi because it's kind of a
crazy irrational number that never that
if you were to write it you couldn't
even you know you could never completely
write pi
3.14159 keeps going on never a repeat
so we just leave it as pi but if you
wanted to figure it out you can get a
calculator and this would be 3.14
roughly times 128 so it would be like
you know close to close to 400 cubic
centimeters now how would we find the
surface area how would we find the
surface area of this figure over here
well part of the surface area the two
surfaces the top and the bottom so that
is this that would be part of the
surface area and then the bottom over
here would also be part of the surface
area so if we're trying to find the
surface area let's do surface
let's find the surface area of our
cylinder it's definitely going to have
both of these areas here so it's going
to have the 16 pi centimeter squared
twice this is 16 pi this is 16 pi square
centimeters so it's going to have 2
times
16 pi
centimeters squared i'll keep the units
still so that covers the top and the
bottom of our soda can and now we have
to figure out the surface area of this
thing that goes around and the way i
imagine it is imagine if you were trying
to wrap this thing with wrapping paper
so let me just draw let me just draw a
little dotted line here so imagine if
you were to cut it just like that cut
the side of the soda can and if you were
to kind of unwind if you were to unwind
this the thing that goes around it what
would you have well you would have
something
you would end up with a sheet of paper
where this length right over here this
length right over here is the same thing
as this length over here
and then it would be completely unwound
and then
these two ends let me do this magenta
these two ends these two ends used to
touch each other and i'm doing a color
that i haven't used yet i'll do it in
pink these two ends
used to touch each other when it was all
rolled together and they used to touch
each other right over there so the
length of this side and that side is
going to be the same thing as the height
as the height of my cylinder so this is
going to be eight centimeters and then
this over here is also going to be eight
centimeters and so the question we need
to ask ourselves is is what is going to
be what is going to be this this
dimension right over here how far and
remember that dimension is essentially
how far did we go around around the
cylinder well if you think about it
that's going to be the exact same thing
as the circumference of either the top
or the bottom of the cylinder so what is
the circumference
the circumference of this circle right
over here which is the same thing as the
circumference of that circle over there
it is 2 times the radius times pi
or 2
pi times the radius 2 pi times 4
centimeters which is equal to 8
pi
8 pi centimeters so this distance right
over here is a circumference of either
the top or the bottom of the cylinder is
going to be 8
pi
centimeters so if you want to find the
surface area of just the wrapping just
the part that goes around the cylinder
not the top or the bottom it's going to
when you unwind it it's going to look
like this rectangle
and so its area
the area of just that part is going to
be equal to eight centimeters times
eight pi centimeters
so let me do it this way it's going to
be eight centimeters
times
eight pi centimeters eight pi
centimeters and that's equal to 64
pi 8 times 8 to 64. you have your pi
centimeters centimeters squared so one
you want the surface area of the whole
thing you have the top you have the
bottom we already threw those there and
then you want to find the area of the
thing around we just figure that out so
it's going to be plus
64 pi
centimeters squared and now we just have
to calculate it
so this gives us 2 times 16 pi
is going to be equal to 32
that is 32 pi centimeters squared
plus 64 pi
64 pi let me scroll over to the right a
little bit
plus 64 pi centimeters squared and then
32 plus 64 is 96
pi
96 pi
centimeters squared so it's equal to 96
pi
square centimeters which is going to be
a little bit over 300 square centimeters
and notice when we did surface area we
got our answer in terms of square
centimeters that makes sense because
surface area it's a two-dimensional
measurement we think about how many
square centimeters can we fit on the
surface of the cylinder when we did the
volume we got cubed or we got
centimeters cubed or cubic centimeters
and that's because we're trying to
calculate how many how many
one by one centimeter cubes one by one
by one centimeter cubes can we fit
inside of this structure and so that's
why it's cubic centimeters anyway
hopefully that clarifies things up a
little bit